a local animal rescue burglarized and
the animals inside terrorized
those at hearts alive village are still
rattled after their pet supply store
was smashed and robbed this week sasha
loftus joining us live near rainbow in
charleston with more on their message to
the community
brian the door here at hearts alive was
completely smashed
and is now boarded up now it appeared
that those
who cut their hands on the glass while
breaking this door
then painted over the mess you can see
with paint here on the sidewalk just
quite a mess outside of this rescue
those here at hearts alive say they're
upset this happened but it was the
animals who were really affected
this was entirely shattered there was
glass everywhere
a spot meant for sanctuary shaken and
smashed
it looks like they cut themselves there
were blood droplets all over here
and they tried to cover it up with paint
those here at hartson live village
are putting their pets supply store back
together
after it was broken into and burglarized
tuesday
it happens but you never expect that
they're going to come inside and really
threaten the safety of the animals
the animals weren't hurt but they were
terrorized
some were found hiding behind doors
while others were taken to the vet
frightened and vomiting they took our
ipad which is our point of sale system
so you know while we are open right now
we're not able to
take credit cards so it's also kind of
hurting our business because we are a
pet supply store
about 150 dollars was also taken
that may not seem like much but for a
non-profit like this
every sense is crucial we have to think
what could that have been used for how
many animals could we have helped with
that
now as hearts alive continues to clean
up
they're asking for help we're grateful
for our community
supporting us and being here during this
time so they can continue to serve
animals and their families all across
southern nevada
now cheryl says their security system
failed the night of the burglary on
tuesday night so they didn't get any
footage
of the break-in if you have any idea
what may have happened have any
information you are urged to contact
metro police
if you'd like to make a donation to
hearts alive village we have information
to do that
on our website 8newsnow.com reporting
live in las vegas tonight sasha loftis
8 news now